monsieur bonsoir les malheurs les gens
les retrouve bien assez tôt le rire on
en aura toujours besoin
c'est ce qu'avait à dire louis de funès
l'acteur comique le plus apprécié des
français
l'homme dans les grimaces les
ricanements et le rire fit rire et
feront rire encore des millions et des
millions de gens louis de funès est mort
la nuit dernière à nantes des suites
d'un accident cardiaque il avait 68 ans
il avait été victime d'un premier
accident cardiaque en 1975 et depuis il
vivait le plus possible dans son château
de clermont près de nantes où il aimait
taille et les roses louis de funès qui
s'éteint donc en pleine gloire son
dernier film le gendarme et les
gendarmettes date de quelques mois
louis de funès avait tourné plus de 100
films avant de devenir vers 40 ans une
immense vedette populaire la carrière sa
carrière émaillée de quelques morceaux
de choix george v go ah les belles
bacchantes et les spectacles
branquignols de robert dhéry ont été les
premiers pas vers la gloire
au théâtre il y eut le grand succès
d'oscar qui deviendra un film de bodinat
au jeu vous allez aller chercher ses
bijoux
écoutez le cadeau de fiançailles
alors de cette façon sa mère ne pourra
plus rien en 1964 jean giraud qu'il
avait déjà employée dans wii puis va
offrir à de funès le premier film de la
série des gendarmes
c'est l'explosion de sa popularité mais
où l'utilisateur
et voilà c'est reparti la fille que je
sois là
s'ils sont quelquefois on disait mais il
n'est pas commun non non c'est un homme
qui était très très timide des heureux
si vous connaissez pas bien ils avaient
ils avaient ils avaient une peur ils
avaient peu il avait une panique mettez
qui vous vous connaissez bien dès que
vous deveniez un ami alors c'était un
enchantement parce que chaque minute cet
homme voyez quelque chose de drôle que
vous n'aviez pas perçu et il voulait
vous le transmettiez alors rush bon
pleurer de rire avec lui je connaissais
comme homme et c'est un homme plus que
lorsqu'il était à l'aise qu'ils étaient
vraiment très jeune et charmant simple
avec moi avec les gens aimant la vie du
pays
il était un de vos fidèles à l'eau
produit par aux siens s'étaient
appréciés comme les autres est très
fidèle lui c'est un chrétien il
pratiquait régulièrement élèves une fois
très profonde
gérard oury à l'idée d'associer de funès
à bourvil en 1965 le succès du corniaud
est prodigieux il y a là un couple de
comédiens dans le jeu se complètent
admirablement c'est beaucoup moins bien
vous n'avez pas marché je sais pas
encore vous en arrêt devant c'est pas
grave
qu'est ce que je vais devenir moi et
magnéto est vrai mais même les vacances
on fera partir pour l'italie
prenez l'avion qui l'a publiquement vrai
comique c'est à dire un comique de
situation c'est là que la situation
c'est toujours la plus grande situation
du monde c'est un monsieur qui lit son
journal avec une chaise quelqu'un
s'approche on aime ou une bande d'ados
et lit-on dans les pages est capable et
je voudrais arriver à faire un film
comique aviotte un film un film muet
mais c'est très difficile à effet mais
pas muet comme du temps du muet muet
avec tous les bruits les sens mais où
les gens s'ils n'ont pas parlé
qu'est ce qu'ils mangent pour club où
les mots qui parlent trop bon en 1967 la
grande vadrouille battra tous les
records de recettes c'est sans doute
pour de funès le sommet d'une carrière
qui compte une centaine de films de
valeurs très inégale
mamad vous demande est toujours là
soyez avec nous j'avais la langue bien
pendue bon sens nous reprenons numéro 17
qui a fait ça c'est moi veut et où vous
croyez vous à l'opéra va être amusant
sortez méphisto marguerite faust sauter
je ne veux personne dans la salle
lorsque je travaille je ne veux que
berlioz et moi voilà et vol